[Music]
we'll go over one of my games today and
it's a very interesting game I played in
2006 my opponent is a very strong
Grandmaster Sergei TV akov and this
tournament was in Italy and one of the
best tournaments ever played my result
was you know very seven and a half out
of nine and about 2,800 feet the
reigning performance so best performance
I've had so let's go over this game I'm
playing with the white pieces so d4
Knight f6 c4 e6 so TV a club is known
for you know playing this opening for
many many years it's a names of Indian
defense he likes to play so if you play
Knight c3 here he will go Bishop before
and it's considered an expert in this
opening so very experienced and when I
prepare against him I saw that he's
played like so many games in this
opening so I decided to play something
that he's gonna be not as familiar with
sharply Knight f3 move here and he
played b6 and I played a tree here a
Trojan system named after the world
champion petrochine yeah he played like
this many games and in this position he
had some game so he played both moves
there you can play Bishop h6 or you can
play Bishop e7
the reason it's I want to show you the
scheme it's a very simple game you will
see like I didn't do anything really
special in this game but in a crucial
moment I find one move and I'm gonna
stop at that point see if you can find
that one move which will give me a nice
advantage so in opening it's gonna be
you know pretty equal so if they'll be
should a six
I played the e3 move very solid move so
a place d5
9 PT 2 so I played Bishop e7 before
castle Bishop b2 just developing my
pieces now he takes on c4 and what do
you think was the best way to recapture
the pawn here with the knight or bishop
here so if you were playing this game
you will capture back with which piece
aha bishop or Knight okay let's see why
would you capture with the bishop aha
good yes
in August you you would take with the
night yeah well in general in general
its you shouldn't avoid the exchange in
opening so you you know you're going to
exchange some pieces it's important to
exchange to the equal value piece so
here we exchange the bishop for a bishop
and most important thing as mentioned
this will help us to castle okay so
that's why you want to take back with
the bishop because you want a castle and
in order to do that if you take with a
knight you're gonna have to move your
Bishop anyway to castle so that takes
more time and his bishop is pretty
active here if you look at the position
here whose bishop is more active your
bishop or his bishop black Bishop right
and from general this is a general rule
I was taught when I was very small so
it's it's when you when opponent has an
active piece and you have the same type
of piece that is not very active it's a
good idea to exchange it okay so in this
position the way you look at it his
bishop is more active than yours so you
definitely want to exchange it so I took
he takes 90 xe4 and I need few more
whoops here if I can just cancel put my
rock on c1 in some point play before I
have a nice position here yes yes
because otherwise I will take the bishop
then he's gonna have to put the knight
on the side and we know that we don't
want to have a knight on the side of the
board because less squash to go to and
not controlling the central squares okay
so that's why he's gonna take this is
the best move but he replays a very very
good move I think because otherwise he's
just slightly worse now let's see if we
can find his move I like you I'm gonna
flip for a second the board for a moment
you will play with black pieces here so
what do you think is the best move here
for black to try to equalize here that's
a difficult move to find
because he has advantage of the fact
that his King his castle that mine is
still in the center and he can do
something about that
which book any play here to create some
threats
yes this game came a little bit
surprised for me too it's a good move
it's not easy to find though
active active black needs to play more
active here because if he just lets me
castle then I have a slightly better
position 25 you could do that but then I
just call Roxy one or Quincy - can he do
something since I have my pawn on before
can he do something about that since I
kind of advanced a little bit too soon
here my king is still in the middle can
he do something about that which move
correct the move is a five a strong move
here now we will see why this is a good
move as I mentioned if you would have
just played a normal move over to just
castle and I have a slightly better game
but after b5 I would like to cook b5
here but if I play the spoon now it's
not going to be good for me why why
can't I just play b5 looks like a strong
pawn to have here huh but this is losing
a pawn here now Queen d5 see now Queen
d5 attacking the pawn attacking the
knight looks like I can play Queen b3
still protecting both can I
a four correct and now I lose the pond
so see here this nice little sequence
and he he played the right move at the
right time if I had Castle already could
have done some other things also so he
played this move so now Queen a four Oh
Queen Queen a four oh you wanted to go
see six maybe yeah yeah yeah idea would
have been good but the problem is 96
here yeah so okay okay so so I'm pretty
much forced here to take on a five
otherwise he's gonna take my pawn so I
took what do you think he wants to hear
does you want to just recapture warning
has a better idea that he can try to do
because if he captures I can sum nothing
why this again at least slightly better
here better pawn structure
I have better control of the center
exactly b5 see you know he attacks my
night and I have to move the night so
then he can capture the past so I went
at night I can't go back but if you have
a choice you always want to go to the
center so I went night ce-5 and now he
played this move it now looks like he's
putting pressure and now very strong
move you need to find here because if
you allow him to play a roux k4 and
block this pawn then this is going to be
weakness for a long time
see natural thing here would be to just
try to cancel here but if you do that
you can play Roux k4 and then try to
develop it's night and a pawn is a
weakness
absolutely
absolutely play for because you have a
weakness right if you have a weakness
first thing with weak pawn you think
about how can I get rid of this weakness
and by playing a four I will get rid of
this weakness you may think like oh we
can check but in this type of position
you can just simply come up and he
doesn't have really threats to your King
because you're going to move your queen
up and then connect your rope in fact
it's very likely that we'll be in the
endgame and it's an endgame where you
want your king to be in a center right
so it will be very useful to have a king
only to in this position because if it's
an egg endgame my king can quickly get
to the C pawn for example since he
doesn't have a damaged development he
cannot really take advantage of this
idea so not always you have to just
castle and then because sometimes we
have you don't have time to castle you
have to go right away of course if he
had a lines coefficient then I probably
wouldn't do this because my king would
be definitely vulnerable but he doesn't
have a light square Bishop which is very
important and since I have the leading
development here I can actually afford
moving my king up here and he can't
really do much to take advantage of it
so he didn't go for this move because he
didn't see what he can really gain out
of this check it will only help to
connect my ropes so he took so I had to
take back the pawn see in this position
I had a weak pawn he had a good pun by
playing this I exchanged his good pawn
and I don't have a weakness anymore now
he has a weak pawn on c4 c7 so if the
game goes on he's gonna end up with this
weak pawn so while my king is in the
center he placed this c5 move trying to
just exchange this week pawn so he paid
c5
now what should I do now
and also this way he protects his rook
we could do that but I think it's time
to play this move already which move
of course okay it's time to Castle now
because too many open lines you know you
don't want now again to so it's time to
cast because it will also be safe for
the King but also we can get the rook
into the game that's why it's more
important to get the rook into the game
here so he took I think win be six
activating his queen attacking my bishop
and this was an inaccurate move you know
he should have probably taken here but
even though we have the same type of
pawn structure but there is still some
pressure here because you know he's not
as well developed and I will be able to
get my rope here so it's still slightly
better disposition for me but he should
have gone for this continuation so if it
couldn't be six and this turned out to
be an inaccuracy that in a for a long
time now he couldn't play this move
anymore
why which moved you can play now so he
cannot take on before
Bishop III right bishop a tree okay of
course he saw this one it's not like he
missed a small but he was counting on
this reply Queen a6 forcing the exchange
of the Queen's and then he was gonna
capture back with the night I have to
take it I don't have a good way to
retreat so I took now he wants to remove
his rook and in some point protect the
bishop so he can take but it's not gonna
be easy to play this so what you should
do now in a position like this you
always look and try to find that piece
that it's not developed correct and now
it was 94 and this is that moment where
I I said I want you to find this move
here without this move it's possible
that he missed this move or perhaps
underestimated because this is a kind of
a hard move to see without this move
it's it's hard to have any identity okay
yes
okay Knight to d7 he will go rook d8
attacking your knight so let's say you
capture right he takes you take and now
it's a nice tactic little tactic because
of the back rank he takes you take he
takes and you cannot take him because
check and you get mated so this way I
will lose my advantage now and you're
just gonna be a draw okay so it's I want
you to think of this idea and try you
know I'm sure in your games also
sometimes you will have a position like
this where you're kind of stuck and the
natural moves they don't work so you try
to look for some kind of quiet moves
that you know you improve your pieces
basically it's you know you need to
improve one of your pieces here and if
you look carefully which piece you think
in this position white wants to improve
very good knight on f3 needs to be
improved but how
well unfortunately his guarding be two
so he'll take us so I can't go to D -
excellent nighty one but not only this
this is a very strong move not only this
move is now I'm planning to improve the
night what is the second idea behind
this move huh excellency now I want to
play this move and move his night when I
move his night now I can already try to
win this pawn so the multi-purpose move
trying to improve the night but at the
same time cringing the threat of f3 and
now he's in trouble because he can
really exchange this pawn so most likely
now he's gonna lose a pawn but again one
extra pawn against a very strong player
you know it's it's not like guarantee
you win you still have to try to win it
so you'll see now what happened 91 now
he plays rook e8 I think at this point
he realized he's gonna lose a pawn so he
said okay I'm gonna try to have an
active rook because you know a lot of
end games even extra pawn but if
opponent pieces are active then it's
gonna be very difficult to win so what's
the next move here for me
yes
yeah
a white mafia
here or here well you could but you
don't want to do that because he will
just take and if you take and he just
takes back and now he is gonna be okay
it's gonna be just equal okay so we
don't want to take yet uh-huh we could
do that let's but let's let's stretch it
when you have a plan
you stick with a plan okay you made
ninety one what was the purpose behind
ninety one so that's I don't switch core
ninety six now when you choose a plan
you go with that plan okay so what's the
right move here
you could go also ninety three but the
stroller is to play f3 you play this
movie attack tonight now what is he
gonna do now he needs to move the knife
yeah but if he moves the night then we
can just take upon so if he moves the
night we could actually take and we are
up upon okay so now he decided to play
this tricky move Bishop g5 leaving his
Knight hanging but attacking my pawn
only three and now if I take this will
be bad for me because he able to go
check attacking the king in a rook then
he would take I would take any we just
take the pond so I lose my rook I lose
two pounds and now maybe I have to try
to find a way to draw the skin
but he's got two pounds value of the
rook and two pounds seven value of two
minor piece is six so technically we're
down upon the most we can get is a draw
here I think most okay so now he plays
this move activating the bishop now you
need to protect this and you don't want
to play a four because then he will just
simply go back and see now this night is
very strong there is I cannot move this
Knight anymore from here
so very interesting he is basically
doing an active defense instead of just
going back he's trying to counter-attack
but you need to find this accurate move
here
how can you protect the e3 pawn very
good night to see for protecting the
pawn and again the threat is still
remaining he still you know we have this
threat okay but now which pawn this pawn
yeah yeah but I already show that line
if you take it's not very good because
he takes check and takes your rock too
so you lose the rook the rook is very
valuable piece okay so you don't want to
do that so 9 c4 but again if he just
goes back you take the pawn ok now he
plays another move 97 leaving his Knight
hanging okay so now okay I took tonight
but now he plays this tactic the rook
takes a three do you see the who's who
sees the idea behind this move now why
did he do that
August check and take see very clever
way he played here instead of just
losing a pawn again now he is doing some
tactics I cannot take the rook because
now he plays Bishop e3 check and takes
my rook on c1 now I need you to make a
move that will stop the threat and
creating a very strong threat you
eliminate history and you created strong
threat now yes
you could try to go Knight f3 but he
might be able to take check take take I
take but he just goes back and yeah I
think it's probably gonna be a draw here
okay so the problem is our rook as you
can see because when he takes check here
we ever problem the rook is hanging so
what can we do about the rook b1
excellent move rook b1 the point of this
move is you move away from this strong
thread Bishop e3 and at the same time
you're creating your own thread
background checkmate
see that's what you're trying to do now
you wanna now you stopped history and
you creating the background check me now
you have two threads actually background
checkmate and just take the knight so he
is he's forced to play this move now
he's got only one move here
yes King f2 probably not probably both
moves are not very good he just takes
now and see the problem and if 92 the
problem is this move now this rook is
too active pinning me and I might mine I
might be big trouble here maybe losing
even because I can't just move this
Knight now I can move this Knight I'm
pinned so I guess I can move this maybe
I'm not losing but yet it's not that
good I mean this is just a very strong
move when you find this move is just you
gotta go for it because now he's forced
to play which move now what is the only
move that he can play here because
otherwise he's just losing rook AAA see
it's a good way to force the piece to go
back okay you put your hook on open file
stop his threads and force his active
to go back so this is a good way to do
it and now finally what do we do now
finally kishka
yeah pun right so we take the pawn now
I'm up upon but I have this double pawns
here they're double pawns but in fact
they're pretty strong because they're
guarding a lot of squares so see for
example this knight can never come here
so they look weak but actually they
guard a lot of important squares here so
position is close to be winning but
still I have to show good technique and
this guy is very experienced so if you
give him a chance you might try to come
up with some drawing chances back here
Knight - d - yeah III think I've looked
at that I've looked at this more I was
probably gonna play I think they're both
pretty bad because in this position also
the point of the 92 movies again trying
to deflect this piece so this will be
very bad because of Bishop e3 idea check
and he takes the knight so so I think I
was planning to play King F Q now I
think probably Knight takes Knight and
rook takes huh but wait he can take now
so there must be something better here
for me because if he managed to take
then he could be okay so we need to find
a better move here let's see let's try
to find a better move here for white
okay so I think I remember now I think
f4
now the bishop is under attack so black
needs to take first the difference is
now his bishop is under attack so now he
probably goes back here and yeah we just
probably go Knight d3 and so we will end
up again with extra pawn here it's
possible actually this could be better
version because at least now I'm not
very active with the rule it's possible
that night b2 could be an improvement so
but plate 97 I cook and Ruby one is very
important moving I place here and I'm up
upon although my pawns are weak so we
place King f8 trying to bring his King
into the game and also you know this
stops the background thread now which
piece now you want to bring into the
game here not only one absolutely
yeah you could go to d3 is there any
other square you can go to that you can
ah ha after to get a temple right we
bring the knight to f3 and we attack the
bishop
that's a temple right remember that now
after I played this move he plays rook a
for another active idea you know I'm
attacking his Bishop II he's activating
his rook and now if I take the bishop he
will take my knight so this will be some
chances for him
well b8 he just comes up
night 2d2 night f.2d - we need to keep
tonight on c4 - protective III pass so
we go night FD - and now I'm already
ready to activate my rook to the seventh
rank to move this night away and start
pushing the C pawn okay so night f - D -
he plays King to e7
I could go route p7 but I decided that I
also should bring my King into the game
because the pawns are weakened in the
end game you want to bring the King to
be closer to the center
so I played King f2 now he's pinning me
so I cannot move my knight King f3 see
this this pawn is really restricting
this night if the knight comes into the
game it's gonna be more difficult for me
but his Knight is misplaced here and he
cannot really come in so my pawns are
actually doing a good job restricting
his pieces now my king is also closer to
the center after King f3 Knight goes
rook c2 and now
what can you do now
you could go to p7 but then he has this
d7 square maybe for his King
a 95 King c8 maybe well your rock will
be hanging here the rock will be hanging
so the better option is to go with c6
first to control the square and then you
go to be same then you'll be forced to
go King d8 okay
remember you have a passed pawn try to
push it yeah of course you have to make
sure you don't lose it but here this
gives me some control of squares too so
I played c6 now he goes through k2 by
the way black really cannot do much if
we can really activate his pieces so
he's really stuck here so he goes rook a
to and now next few moves I'm just
activating all my pieces here now we're
very close to the victory here very
close
now which piece we need to activate
first absolutely rook belongs on a
seventh rank and especially when you do
this you pin him so he is forced to play
the only move King d8 now now we need to
activate our Knights okay
we can't move this night because this
night is hanging right night b-tree
correct he goes rook a6 attacking the
pawn Knight to e5 f 6 9 f7 check King c8
only move
they wants to take your pawn here it
could go 94 but improve the position of
the night first on f7 96 Shak King goes
back to the 8th now we need to protect
so we go 94 so as you can see in just
fumes now I have my own eyes very active
my rook on a seventh rug and I protected
my pawn on c6 now rook e8 you can't
really do anything it's really very rare
where he could win a game like this
against very she's about 2,700 player
give you a call very experienced player
so now I go spook a8 Knight takes pawn
check very nice because I have the king
and the mating net right checkmate
so he didn't take that so he goes here
only move there are many ways to win
here but which which move is the best
here what do you think
well in fact yeah it's really I could
just take I didn't do that though yes
well that's the trick if you do that he
takes this night there could be a
problem I actually wanted to meet him
and I think I got I could just take the
night of course it's just ease the
winning that's what I did I played 95
check so now he has to take and I simply
take tonight threatening checkmate
I was I was expecting it you know but
but but this was very important game
this was the one wrong before the last
you know so it was a big tournament and
you know pretty big prize fund also so
so he was upset yeah well we're still
trying to make the 40 moves I guess
maybe that's I don't know so now he took
my night I cook and here he realized
that he's gonna get mated or he plays
rook e8 what do you do check it was bad
now we go check he goes here and now we
should just go rook d7 here and now
we're still threatening checkmate no
it's not really a checkmate but but yeah
the pawn is going into its I mean
threatening meeting to actually check so
he probably has to play this move now if
he doesn't want to get made it but check
anyway just you know we can just
everything wins you can just take and
push the C pawn okay so yeah he resigned
here after rooks e7 move after I played
rook c7 he resigned here we had some
time so I'm going to do a couple of
positions okay see if you can solve
these positions
now okay white to play and you can make
a draw in this position okay you need to
find a very strong idea here what do you
think what you can do here to be able to
draw all right keep the king out okay
that would be nice but it's not so easy
why to play and draw yeah
night yeah
palms are going this way yeah and you're
going this way you're down upon but you
can you can draw this game well if you
go to King g3 he's gonna go King II won
and if you try to win his pawn he's
gonna get behind if once he gets behind
your opponent gonna lose because you can
only take one pawn and it takes your
pawn and then he can just simply promote
his pawn okay so that's why and you
can't really stop him from even if you
play this move here you're eventually
gonna run out of moves after King B -
aha well if you go King g1 he goes King
II won you have to come up then it goes
king he - if you move it here he goes
King f1 and he gets behind it when the
King gets behind you lose okay there is
only one move here you can play here
that is not gonna allow him to do that
what did you say okay
King h1 yes it looks very strange you
move away from your pawn but by playing
this move you actually get the
opposition and this is called distant
opposition okay he can't get behind the
f1 that's the whole point
now if he comes here what do you do
Jiwon if he now comes up kingi - he goes
here i goes here see if you have to then
I can get behind it so again you try to
keep the opposition okay you and make
sure there are three squares between
both Kings okay so that's distant
opposition here so you go king gage tree
and again there are three squares
between each king so now he goes back
king h2 now it was back to d1
and I placed g4 aha see the final trick
I did and you took a car and that's a
quick
push push unfortunately he Queens with
the check if you didn't clean what the
check would have been great but he wins
now when he plays this move it's you
don't need to rush to see maybe you can
do something else it's not like you were
forced to take excellent King up to g2
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]